what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
that pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos guys
there are a hundred people in here right
now i better see 50 likes on the video
while you're at it guys sign up for our
memberships to be a part of our discord
that we are dropping this week and some
exclusive behind the scenes content so
we have a lovely panel today
so why don't we go around and everyone
say your name your age your relationship
status and where you are from
hello guys jt aka king babs back on the
show i'm 25 years old i'm single and i'm
from hackney
all right um i'm jess i'm from
california i'm 28 years old and
and i'm single
hi i'm octavia
i'm 25 i'm single as well
i'm from cambridge but i've lived in
london for a while now
my name is stefan i'm from hackney
originally and i am single bachelor
[Music]
name's alexander
i am from london and i'm single
okay so
today's topic is has feminism actually
helped women get better outcomes
um i wanted to go around and get
everyone's opinion on that topic
starting with you
guess
outcomes yeah for women for women yeah
specifically um
i think that's subjective um i would say
yes if we're talking about
um
actually
if the outcome was to
uh get women's
problems or
um
the fight
of womanhood uh more known to the masses
i said feminism has done that i would
argue yes has gotten the fight of
womanhood known to the masses yeah um in
terms of um
let's say some of the prejudices that
the
uh that women
have felt that they've dealt with over
the years um has it pushed that agenda
to for it to be
more known i would say yes because from
a man's perspective
um not myself but a lot of men didn't
know of it okay okay what do you think
jess
um
in terms of
them
having a better outcome for women
overall
no if the outcome was for
women to
not be married and just be
independent their whole lives then i'd
be like oh yeah they
met it and like they didn't want to have
kids or get married that was never
like a woman's thought oh they succeeded
but
the women that
are feminists
are going down that road but they still
want to be married and have kids it's a
little bit of a struggle so i will say
no no okay what do you think
yeah again i feel like it depends on how
you define the outcomes i feel like i'm
kind of
in between a bit because i feel like
it's kind of showing that women can have
some different options so
um they can kind of still live
more how we're used to in the past if
they want to but also there's another
route um
but i can see why people are finding it
problematic because it's maybe more of a
pressure for women to be independent and
so maybe it might be like harming some
women who prefer to have a more
traditional life i suppose but again i
think it depends on how you define
outcomes like personally for you what
are your values and is it helping those
values okay
i do not think that feminism has been
good for society as a whole i think that
people are less likely to get married
they're less likely to create families
the
child birth rate has gone down which
kind of feeds the system of society
where we have more workers more
taxpayers who then look after the old
the disabled
uh things like that i think it's
you're seeing it more people single than
ever before and i think it's been a
disaster
um i would probably say
i i think it's subjective i think
depending on the metrics you use if you
come at it from a perspective of
society's ability to
um sustain itself and you know people
having kids and etc then i would say
definitely no but if you look at it from
a perspective of people
developing as individuals i would say
feminism has allowed women to
um enter a lot more spaces they wouldn't
have been allowed to and to grow in ways
that they would have probably you know
not been allowed to so it's subjective
would you say that women are happier
today
than they were in say 1920. i think
women are confused
why
um because with
i can't lie i'm confused
[Laughter]
um i think
the subject of feminism has has brought
about a lot of confusion
for some women um
because um a lot of them
uh do not understand
uh
the
originality of it and um what is
why feminism was created in the spaces
so
um i know a lot of people that they
think they're feminists they want to be
feminists but really and truly they
don't really know what it is so i don't
know if it has helped
yeah
did you know that women didn't actually
want the right to vote the majority of
women
second wave feminism right
no the first wave i would say because uh
i was i was under the impression that
under second wave feminism uh they were
going to be conscripted into the army
and then as a
because they were wanting the right to
vote and then it was voted on and pushed
down see rolo tomasi argues that there
was only one feminism that there was no
first wave second wave third ways that
it's oh it is and has always been a
supremacy movement
and hi really yeah i would agree with
that what's your thoughts on that
um
let me find the hold on let me find this
article
i mean yeah i mean i don't think it's
about equality i think feminists hate
man
they genuinely hate men and personally i
think it's resulted in much worse
outcomes for women because one in four
women are at anti-depressants does that
seem like it's going well for us
why would you why would you say they
hate men why would i say they hate you
yeah that's a bit strong isn't it
because they don't think all feminists
hate men
okay so there is a there is a feminist
who decided to do documentary on the
male um
basically she was talking about men the
men's rights movement right which
advocates for things like child support
yeah um
men's shelters like we have women's
shelters men's shelters and men losing
everything in divorce yeah and feminists
were like
protesting this this
this video because this she was a
feminist and she went into the men's
rights movement and then she thought oh
they actually have a point
there's actually a lot of systems that
are against men feminists don't advocate
for them why don't we ever hear
feminists talk about
child support why don't we ever hear
feminists talk about alimony why don't
we ever hear feminists talk about men's
rights issues it's always about the
women
if they really wanted equality why don't
they fight for both because they
probably feel like for a long time it
hasn't
been in their favor so
now is the time that they're choosing to
to speak on it they wouldn't care what
they wouldn't care what it means for the
man so how has it not been in our favor
when we never had to fight in wars
so okay we didn't have the right to vote
you could say that we were oppressed but
you could also say men were oppressed
because they had to go fight and we
didn't
for
okay true
that's why i said it's it's subjective
because
um that's one side of the argument fair
enough you may not have been able to
fight
in wars um
i don't know
back when you know we were more um when
wars were more common i don't know how
many women would have wanted to go and
fight in the war right
so that's it
um
you could say we had an advantage over
men
yeah
yeah you could say that but from what i
understand is um
perhaps the option to
go to war wasn't there
for the woman
um well that's why the women didn't want
the right to vote
was because we didn't want to get
drafted because if you're able to vote i
don't know how it is here but in the us
if you're able to vote you're free range
to get drafted into the war
and so once that
law was passed that women
canvo is like well i don't want to vote
because i don't want to go to the war i
don't want to be drafted so
so feminism um it all started in 1848 in
seneca falls new york the suffrages had
200 men and 100 women um in the 1920s
they were seen as terrorists planning
assassinations
i didn't know that yeah they were seen
like they're seen as antifa as seen
today
the suffragettes were intense yeah
that's new information to me i i would i
would definitely say that
to feminism for me seems like a very
sophisticated and kind of sinister way
of kind of destroying people from the
inside out
just from my experience with feminism
from reading that ideologies and
refining refinery 29 those kind of
journalism kind of websites they have a
very very biased
perspective and it's almost like um
a cult because you have to buy into the
overall message which is that
we were always at the bottom and then
they used that to justify this very
lopsided bias world view that then they
used to justify
more and more
extreme kind of well it's it's a victim
mentality and i don't understand like
how am i how how am i at any
disadvantage in 2022 being a woman
what do i don't need to be fought for
what do they need it's not empowering i
don't know i don't know how it's seen as
empowering you know to say that you're a
victim and then having like a lot of the
beliefs where it's like we've been
suppressed for this many years there's
something over
i don't know i don't think that's
empowering if you're really trying to
empower people so what do you
uh
think
you don't think
about like do you think women are
oppressed now in 2022
um
no i don't think they're oppressed not
in 2022
um
but you can argue that the the movement
of feminism
um
has led has led for it to be that way
has led
oh you're saying has led for us not to
be oppressed
i would i would argue that we were never
oppressed it was just about trade-offs
and choices
how would you define oppressed
um to the point where you
you're not entitled to certain
privileges
i feel like for
a lot of um the feminists that i know
for a lot of them it's not so much about
the argument of
going to wars or having children but
more so um
in a working environment
and
the the freedom or
the right to be set at certain tables
they may have had the
the skills the knowledge
to to compete with the men
however they were overlooked how did
madame curry do it
madam curry
um i'm not too familiar with this story
she was the first um first female
millionaire or billionaire in the u.s i
think million i don't remember if it's a
millionaire a billionaire
but that wasn't like the early 1900s how
did she do it
it doesn't seem like she was that
oppressed
no because she could have been an
exception to the rule i'll say even in
like if you look at like british history
it didn't make sense to me that there
are like queens like our highest figures
in english history like queen elizabeth
et cetera and i'm thinking so we had
this patriarchal society but the most
powerful person the society was a woman
you know
for me it didn't really like
align
um but i'm not well well read on well
and the other thing is maybe women
didn't want to work
like i mean i feel like they duped us
because one if we just waited a little
longer we would have got roombas and
[ __ ] you know what i mean
[Music]
that happened to work
you don't even like how do you how do
you know like why do we blame it on
oppression like maybe it was just their
choices
and like back then marriage and family
like that was more valued in society
and plus they didn't have the opt-out of
birth control so it's about like
trade-offs and choices
perhaps
um
i mean
you're going i would say that there was
see
i was i would i would i was a feminist
for a little bit and i do see there's a
lot of kind of situations and industries
where
i don't see it as oppression but where
like society has taken a while to catch
up to what is possible now so maybe
before women weren't allowed to do xyz
because of
you know um there weren't any wasn't any
birth control right so certain careers
were off limits because they wouldn't
want you to like just randomly just quit
and have to have a family which would
make sense or maybe
you know women's hygiene projects one
didn't exist
at the time so
you know when women couldn't really be
in certain tight spaces like with
factory workers uh the way i see it is
that there was oppression in well
i felt like society just lagged in
allowing people allowing women to enter
certain spaces based on tech not just
like men being bad or like people were
just like trying to be mean
would you would you argue that that
feminism
um
is liberating to men
liberates me no
you don't think so i think it's
systematically and very innovative
sophisticated way it tries to break men
down
um
to be
less lesser than what they should be in
order to kind of
determines what a man should be
um
reality results society and i think it's
a level of self-determination and
development as a human being and a lot
of the ideology i see coming from
feminism and how men should be on in
their best interest for example crying
being emotional being someone who's like
more passive in order to make the women
around them feel more kind of it just
doesn't seem to me like you're giving
people i think it's unnatural to make
them better it seems you're giving
people advice to make you feel better
about them well it's giving it's giving
it's confusing to men
because women say that they want
emotionally available men then men do it
and we're like i'm not that emotionally
it's like
like a standard like
when women say oh we want this this and
this but it comes with like
we want that but not not too much don't
give it to us too much like yeah we want
you all to be vulnerable and emotional
but don't don't don't do it too much
like you're crying in front of me oh no
like you can do that in the room cry in
the room and then come back and
it's
it's annoying sometimes it
i'm like why am i a woman why because
it's so it's like the way we think is
annoying
to the fact that it's like y'all can't
understand what we're saying and
sometimes we don't even understand what
we want or what we're saying yeah
and
yeah but i have a question for you do
you think men can be feminist
do you think men can be
no
not no i don't i don't think so i think
a lot of the feminists i know
the men the male feminists are
unknowingly doing it for a certain end
maybe they're using it as a way to get
close to certain women so i have some
very good friends who i've just felt
like we've had conversations where you
know he'll say something like yeah you
know these other guys at my top
university you know that
they do this and that and i you know i
i'm different because i can have like
um they're leftovers
[Laughter]
non-sexual relationships with women and
you know and then i asked them so
have you ever dated one of your female
friends i was like well he says well my
last two actors were
friends so it's like so
if you date your friends
then surely that makes your your beliefs
very convenient for you dating-wise then
isn't it because so it's not
what's the word for when it's like not
um
no sexual intention
plutonic it's not plutonic if you date
your friends
um and so in my view i think they're
just unknowingly or subconsciously using
that ideology as a way to advance
themselves in a dating market is that
what you did because you said you were a
feminist for a little bit oh yeah
did you do it to get the girls oh um
listen
i had a time where the man
to speak such a nice guy
i had a time where like you know you
know when you're like you're in high
school you get into youtube when you're
watching all these extreme videos about
like tin foil hats the illuminati jay-z
rihanna
and i got into the feminist thing so i
you know i read some of their books one
of buddhist buddha's daughters when i
was traveling around thailand and now
women are generally seen as second-class
citizens in buddhism
they're seen as people who are incapable
of reaching certain levels of spiritual
attainment
purely based on the fact that they're
female and so there was a point where
i heavily associated or sympathize with
with the basic premise of feminism but i
never outright call myself a feminist
i think men have a natural inclination
to protect women too just like in you
guys biology
so i think a lot of times when like
girls are advocating for a cause they'll
get their like beta boyfriends to go
with them
every every big fight has been typically
involved in a woman
yeah always
100 especially and it's crazy these guys
will literally
put their lives on the line for not even
the woman that's had their kids
it's like some random girl natural
selection though
i don't i mean i'm still struggling over
the idea that a man will become a
feminist
to
essentially um
attract a woman or because if we're
saying that um the majority
um of of of women don't like a man who
cries a man then gonna start crying to
impress like one woman it doesn't is
that what it's not that necessarily it's
like if it was flipped and there was um
it was men men were i don't know what
the word would be um
and y'all were in your group talking
about men's stuff personally i would
not become but i would want to
be knowledgeable in the sphere of the
male feminism so i can understand like
okay what are they talking about what
can i do to not like be extreme but i
can be like oh yeah i understand y'all
like oh just to like fit in so
it's not necessarily so you're not
really
like yeah you wouldn't really be it's
like you're undercover you're like okay
i know what y'all like i can understand
it a little bit i can see it i can
finesse my way through it i won't be too
vulnerable but i'll just be enough to be
like oh my gosh he's so different
that's pretty much what it is well
my issue with when my friends got into
this some of my male friends were like
oh i'm a feminist now was like so were
you sexist before then
like were you were you just walking
around
why did you feel the need all of a
sudden to take on this mantle that you
conveniently have to tell everyone
around you about especially the women
like you aren't sexually assuming yeah
because
you don't know a feminist man that just
keeps it to himself
you know it's the the women will know at
some point he'll be going to like
female rugby games it's like you don't
even watch any sports why why are you
all of a sudden interested in female
rugby because your female friends are
and some of them are cute so why are
they the creepiest guys as well like why
are they the guys they're always they're
always
like they're the guys at the at the
party they're
you know getting getting a girl drunk
and
i'm gonna look after our take her home
stuff like that
what do you think of octavian wow what
do you think about that tell me to give
my example yeah yeah yes we're talking
about the stories
yeah i have another point to make but i
can make that in a bit but um
yeah i was because these guys were
asking me earlier like oh do you know
any like male feminist and i was like i
don't think i really
talk to guys that say things like that i
tend to go for guys that maybe if they
have used they're more low-key they
wouldn't say i identify with this
ideology
but there's one guy and he
was he he says he's a feminist and i
think he's a communist as well he's got
his strong ideologies
i didn't mention that
and basically he just said to me one day
that the best time he's had sex with a
woman is when she was like crying in the
middle of it and i was like
oh
wow i said fetish crazy wow
it freaked me out so much i was like how
can this guy think that he's got good
morals but then do stuff like this i
think it's these people that identify
with these big ideologies that behind
closed doors are like one-on-one with
people they're not actually nice to
people like they say these things to
make themselves seem good but then
actually as a person they don't have the
best values so that's my experience with
that guy anyway wow
[Laughter]
you said you had some other thoughts
involving this guy as well to be honest
so i think
there's probably like a group of people
that call themselves feminists that are
very like
vocal and like are putting men down and
saying oh men need to be more emotional
and then like you you guys were saying
earlier like they'll even go for the
guys that are more masculine even though
they're putting them down with their
ideology behind closed doors they're
having sex with the guys that are more
like alpha etc
but yeah this this guy
i feel like i'm quite a logical person
like i would want a guy to like uh open
up and be a bit emotional but if they're
too much then
i feel like it's just intelligence at
that point like if you're literally
pouring out emotions over someone that
like doesn't want you and you keep like
sending like toxic messages and all of
this like at this point it's not
feminism that's caused you to do that
like surely you have some critical
thinking skills that mean that you
wouldn't go that far
like yeah this guy was
sending crazy toxic emails
like there was one time where he kept
emailing you after he was yeah he like
blocked he um he saw a video of me
dancing with another guy platonically
and then he blocked me and emailed me
saying after one date
uh it was a complicated situation with
him maybe a couple dates okay um
but yeah now he saw this and then he
blocked me and then um
sending toxic emails and stuff and then
yeah one time we were lying in bed and i
was like i'm just tired i want to go to
bed like just literally tired and he was
like what have i done wrong like what
can i do like all of this and i was like
i'm just tired because i know it's crazy
as women we want a guy that leads us and
so when we feel like like we're the ones
in control more in control of our
emotions than them it's like tiring it's
like you feel like their mother
yeah i was like why can't you just
literally tell me how you feel but like
surely going overboard is like obvious
that you're not supposed to do that as a
person yeah it's just lacking emotional
intelligence i'm sorry i'll actually add
something to that with the tell me how
you feel thing and it's more so
i learned from
girls that have been in the game right
that
a guy when she asks you or tell me how
you feel it's a trick
because the moment you tell her how you
feel you've lost the point do you think
she'll use it against you or something
it's not even that she may use it
against you with intention it will be
like unintentionally like you get into
an argument and
women and men are different when it
comes to arguments men have a line and
women when they want to get into an
argument there's no line they won't
cross
i'm not like that personally you know
i'm not like this
octavia is extremely extreme extremely
rational yeah she's one of those
one of the rare women that i feel like
says exactly
what she wants and she understands it
where i speak to a lot of feminists who
tell me they want xyz and i'm looking at
like but your ex all your exes are the
exact opposite of everything you just
said
um updated feminists who telling me yeah
be emotional i really want to be there
for men and i've told them like
oh i don't get on with this person then
when we broke up she was like you were
dumping on me emotionally
you know from experience
but the thing is i was a feminist so i
had to learn this stuff from practically
actually like engaging with people and
being like this stuff is not practical
you know what's crazy when you think
about it what feminism advocate when
feminine feminism advocates for men it's
always for women really because they're
advocating for men to be more
emotionally available but who does that
benefit the men as well women are the
women just women nah it's leverage so
for for your example of um
um when you're seeing someone i was
telling you to be more like emotionally
available and
uh you've done that right you've done
that
in a way i told her about my
frustrations okay and when you broke up
she said that you were dumping on on her
yeah a whole diet about men using women
as emotional
experts right but when you
uh
when you
he's adopted emotionally right if i can
say it like that uh to a degree because
you're still you're not much of another
extremely alpha yeah
how how
how did you feel
how did you feel
when
you um
and you were you opened up emotionally
ever so slightly terrible see opening up
emotionally doesn't really
and i would i would go as far to assume
this is how all men work
opening up emotionally does not solve
the problem it just gives another person
leverage to then criticize you about how
you're reacting to the problem so but
then you're ripped the wrong guy i mean
well the wrong person
because
so do you think that a woman can take on
a man's problems
no i don't
correct me if i'm wrong i don't think
when a woman is telling you like to to
open up this so that she can take on
your burden or
or
or whatever i don't i don't think that's
the case for me personally um and again
i might be um an exception to the rule
and paul hates the exception still
um
but my ex she's she's a feminist right
and which acts
um
she's the ironic thing she's american as
well
might be watching this um
yeah but she's um she's a feminist and
um when
it
i grew up very much like i would say
most men to the point where where you
know we're trained to be this alpha male
alpha present so with a lot of the time
i wouldn't i'll be going through things
and i wouldn't speak out about it and
yeah it did come to the point where it's
like yo like why like what is it like
why don't you you know you speak out
more about about what is
and it was hard for me because i wasn't
trained to do that but then
it's i tried it with one fact i just
said something and it was something that
was hurting me for a long long time
you know some some trauma that i had
went through
uh as a young person um so when i said
that
it
it for my relationship anyways it helped
us because it removed some of the
the the frictions in communication and
she was able to understand me better
because of what i said because i would
just be reacting to things and she
wouldn't really know where it stemmed
from
so so
but you realize the original problem is
you weren't in control of your emotions
to begin with
because you were reacting to things and
then she was noticing yeah but i wasn't
reacting in the best way right right but
that's that's like where it started from
though the problem is you not
controlling your emotions to begin with
right did who did you break up with her
did she break up with you
we both did she break up with you
like that honestly who started the
conversation honestly we had an amicable
mutual breakup it's never it's never
mutual did you cheat no no
but it was both of us that's not the
point if it wasn't your idea you didn't
initiate in your mind i understand if
she may have made you think it was that
it was really not
probably
i went through it i know no it wasn't
this guy
you see i'm getting red pill on camera
no it was it wasn't that it wasn't that
at all i think with me it all stems from
what i was saying i probably would was
thinking about it but i never i never
like vocalized it so then the
relationship become became toxic and
with me and her we were friends like
before so we all we always agree that
we'll protect the friendship when it was
coming to the point where the
relationship was
was becoming slightly toxic because of
what i wasn't you know what i was
harboring and overthinking in my head it
came to a point was just like yo where
are we going with this we need to call
it but we're cool i spoke to her today
she's cool
so you're still friends yeah yeah yeah
so she kind of like friend zoned you a
little bit
um
well yeah
yeah she kind of did
that's that's what we do to guys that
are too emotionally available
nah
nah
you learn a game right now
you learn a game right but the reason
the reason why we broke up wasn't
because i was too emotionally available
you you might
you may have you know she may not have
told you that you want to do a poll on
youtube
no no i don't have to do a poll because
i asked her we we we speak um we speak
and
um yeah it wasn't that that wasn't that
wasn't the reason so
but again that might but that might just
be an exception um i don't think it's
like that with most men and most women
um but it just taught my paint was it
just taught me a lot that being um and
don't get me wrong i don't i'm not so
emotional that i'll cry uncontrollably
that's not that's not what i'm saying
but i do feel like um
as men will talk to kind of keep our
emotions in but if we bring it out it
does have benefits well but here here's
the thing there's a difference between a
guy who's very strong yeah and you know
cry like maybe you see him like okay my
dad is someone i i really respect like i
respect my dad more than anyone right
and i've seen him cry twice in my life
but it's like one thing when a guy's a
strong like masculine man and like okay
then he cries
versus like someone that's
not in control of their emotions or
unemotion or um crying all the time and
the point is by and large in general
women prefer
men that are
emotionally unavailable yeah but the
person that cries all the time that
like even if he claims to be a feminist
removing his feminism he has a personal
issue that he has to deal with as to why
but the point is that women are telling
men that they would prefer someone
that's emotionally available which just
by and large isn't true like there are
studies that show that if a woman sees a
guy cry she's less attracted to him
and it's not fun like that doesn't make
women look good
like that's kind of that's kind of an
[ __ ]
but it's just you can't deny it if
there's studies that show this i feel
like there's different ways of
expressing feelings though like you can
express feelings and just break down and
cry and be a complete mess or you can
literally just be like oh by the way
like
my cousins something happened to my
cousin so i'm feeling a bit down that's
it that's like maybe enough to express
yeah and then the the woman or the
partner can be like oh i understand i'll
be a bit nicer blah blah that's way
different than the guy just crying and
like
i don't know maybe attacking her because
he's in a state like this kind of thing
who are these guys i i do not know of
men these are hypothetical i don't know
oh right i don't think anyway let's talk
toxic
no guys that that cry on control of me
that's right that was
guys are normally foreign really yeah
i've had a lot of friends the most
manipulative men are the ones who really
ride on this like we i should be allowed
to be emotional don't shame me for
crying
etc um yeah
i'm not around
and in those relationships or a man
is the typical relationship you see
where a man is more in touch with his
feminine side is usually the woman
that's more of a leader and taking
reigns on the whole relationship
and um and she hates him
yeah she's like he hates him yeah yeah
lucky and she's sleeping with tyrone on
the side
why am i cousin tyrone why chad tyrone
i did find it quite interesting you
touched on um
an interesting point there where when
people say men should be more emotional
i think men and women hear different
things
so
guys men who you know like yourself who
say that i'm a male feminist kind of
here
manage your emotions in an adult way and
then women
other people think of like being
emotional and i think men have always
managed their emotions you know people
went to war had trauma men have always
relied on each other support with each
other um you know there's been therapy
in a lot of different ways i think this
idea that like men are these you know
historic beings who never deal with
their emotions in any way is a bit of an
exaggeration it's used to push this idea
of like being overly weak and emotional
to combat this already extreme kind of
starting point
which is not really consistent with
actual reality
do you guys think that the majority of
women
want children when they're 18.
i would say
yes because of
the way
society was and how like when we're
younger we're practically
pretending to be mothers with all the
baby dolls we have the kitchen sets and
everything so i would say
it's like
instilled in us like oh you're a woman
you're going to have children you may
not want them at 18 but i think in every
woman's mind do you think it's society
or our or our biology
because when i was growing up
really because when i was growing up i
heard a lot of you can do anything you
want you don't need a man you're strong
independent woman from the media
hmm yeah
okay go ahead what do you think 18
as in at 18 you think in the future i
want to have kids yes
so i was i've tried to read a bit on
gender and relationships and things
and
i was reading a theory that basically
we're driven by our genetics and our
genetics want us to reproduce so
i think it's probably a largely
genetic component that men and women
both want to have kids i'm not saying in
like a nuclear family necessarily but
the reason there's so many people is
because we are driven by our genetics
they control us basically so why do you
think 50 of women over 30 are single and
childless
if we yeah if at 18 we wanted children
it by and large to make poor decisions
is that yeah but is that thought oh go
ahead i was gonna say is there a driving
force of
or if you want to call it propaganda
that's pushing a narrative of not having
children that children are pain in the
ass and that it's
a loaf on your careers although everyone
like your life having holidays on the
beach and just having a pina colada you
know it's like
i think people are confused in general
as well they don't know what their
values are they don't know if they value
family more their career because
obviously especially in cities in cities
like london a lot of people are focused
on careers they're not going to be
thinking about having kids i think
people are just like they haven't sat
down and thought what are my values do i
really want to have a family and like
working towards that
do you
think that
when
do you think when women are pushed to
focus on their career
that it comes at the cost of a family
later yeah it can do definitely
and do you think that most women are
happy with that trade-off by and large
in the end i think most people haven't
thought deeply enough about it to be
honest i think people need to really sit
down and think about what they want with
their life and not get distracted by
what other people are saying or like
what society's saying or on the internet
for example
i think some women are i think it's
surface level some are happy but like
they ultimately want their end goal and
i can speak
speak on that because i have friends who
are the same age as me who are career
focused but like they desire to have a
husband desire to have a family but it's
just not
it's like not working out for them and i
think that's a huge problem so many
women are like business business
business me me me me that when it comes
to they don't realize the facts that
once you hit 30 50
of your eggs are gone so you have ninety
percent oh
of your options are gone the options
that you had at 20.
90 once you hit 30
it's like you have a 10 chance now and
so i don't i don't think a lot of women
know that that's not a 10 chance it's i
don't
or you have a lower percentage
i'm going out of 100 90 are gone you
have a lower percentage yeah yeah you're
right one in three women over 30 have
fertility issues yeah so don't you think
there's also like a you know
a societal kind of
personality edge to it where you've
developed as a person this way that now
makes you a very specific person
and now you have to then engage with the
dating market which is foreign
i think women um
i think women are sleeping out of their
league to be honest
yeah i think there's girls that are
five sixes you know pretty cute that are
sleeping with guys that are eights nines
and tens and they think they're on that
level yeah but they're not
so
basically now they're gonna deny
the guys that are actually in their
league
100
i would agree with that and so and so
then they expect they get ran through in
their 20s and expect the beta guy to
pick up the pieces
at the end or still reject the beta guy
and say i'm just gonna i'd rather be
alone
and i asked girls this question would
you see a guy rather see a guy you
really like once every two weeks or a
guy you kind of like twice a week
they always say the the guy i really
like every two weeks
would you say that a lot of them also
distinguish maybe
when a guy wants to sleep with them they
distinguish it as they actually want
them
like on a long-term basis because
commitment to me is it's yeah that's
your level yeah who who can you get to
commit to you because someone's sleeping
with you that's easy you can click your
fingers i mean guys i've heard guys say
things like
what i'm sorry i always say i'd rather
i'd rather have um she was better than
my hand oh
but it's hard
i'll say it's hard for a
majority of women to be able to
engage it in
sex with someone and not be like okay so
like what's next because of just how we
are genetically programmed and i think
that's something that
women um
don't understand is like men don't
really have that connection to sex when
it comes to that it's just like oh we're
just having sex like what do you mean
what's next and that's and that's
another thing feminism lied to women
about is body count they say your body
count doesn't matter sleep with whoever
you want
but every guy i've talked to i ask would
you date a girl and only fans know
do you want a girl that posts her ass on
the internet no
do you want do you want a girl that
slept with over 10 bodies no
and
like
and so the feminists will say oh you're
slut-shaming but they're not thinking
about the outcomes that it results in
for women which for a lot of them is
being by them damn selves
there's a lot of contradiction when it
comes to
feminism i would say because it's
setting it's setting up women for
individual
success
but in the long run
if they want
the
the picture of a family is going to be
harder for them to get it and that's
something that feminism isn't
telling women
that
you can work on this but no you're going
to have to sacrifice this in the end
because if you're focused on you you you
that dream of a family is going to be
smaller and smaller and smaller yeah and
that's and that's the thing i'm all
about women doing what they want to do
if a girl wants to start an only fans
tomorrow
like go ahead i mean that's not my
problem but
be okay with the trade-off like bad
barbie or whatever she made 50 million
in a year 50 to 75 million she's set for
life
trade office she probably won't find a
husband but she she's set for life
that's the trade-off
but is she happy you know ultimately
deep down do women get a lot of
happiness from making loads of money i
wouldn't encourage it i mean
i'd be a lot more happier with 50
million dollars
i would i wouldn't do that but i'm just
saying like i think women should pick
what they want to pick do what you want
to do but be aware of the consequences
and what i don't like is feminism lies
to women as they say you can do this
this this and this and there will be no
consequences and for some if you're hot
enough you know there might not be
i mean
wouldn't you consider that maybe
what they're actually doing isn't
necessarily bad as much as
they will be judged by it by modern men
who may have certain views so for
example only fans right you could do you
can have only fans and like just take
some raunchy photos
that's that's fine right technically
there's nothing is it is it fine i mean
me personally your wife mother of your
children
fine yeah you reckon 50 million you
gotta stop it when we get married and
all that stuff but if you're awake in
money your kids your kids are going to
see it someday you're so you have a son
his mom is the savage his
the other boys in school show the mom's
raunchy photos okay you're talking about
like real famous only fans no no no
literally all it would take was was is
for someone to search up like mom's name
or surname and they find the photos from
back in the day when she was doing only
fans and then
they could literally use it as they're
gonna they're gonna make software that
tracks your face
you put it on the internet it's there
forever
don't matter so like lana rhodes had
this problem right she's trying to get a
load of wanna rhodes
mia mia khalifa
yeah because they want no consequences
they weren't crying when they were
raking in all the money but they're
crying when they have to deal with the
consequences
yeah i'm not too familiar with early
fans is it like um hardcore
it can be anything like it can be i mean
you you don't even it can be non-sexual
if you want but in general women are
putting sexual content because if you
want to make money you have to take
things further mm-hmm sex so yeah and
even the association with it right like
you you find out someone's gotten only
fans like i know there's a guy the first
thing i'm like yeah now yeah i'm good
depends on the goal though i mean if if
she's if she's caught something serious
yeah but depends on the person like if
if if she hasn't only fans account that
is somewhat tasteful and i can
understand that like
what would taste do you do you have no
standards
no it's just
modern modern challenges need modern
solutions right it's tougher so i get it
some women that's the only shot
um and i guess it's a good way of making
money yeah but so i i will do you want
someone that can be sold out that can be
bought you want that is your wife mother
your children
do you want to be the beta that picks up
the pieces
i would not be as quick to jump on on
her case solely based on that i'm
willing to examine it and say you know
if it's tasteful and she's you know
earnestly trying to make
um not trying to kind of um
okay you can bail her out have fun you
ain't gonna wife her though bro
we both noticed you when you got away
guys
what if like she's highly educated
classy girl
some of these like high high upper class
um
you know chaperones if you escort okay
escorts we can say that um and you meet
her and she's very intelligent very
great you get on she's respectful she
says i got all your fans account you
look at it it's some raunchy photos but
no no like
no um key areas exposed in a way that
would be overly embarrassing has this
happened to you before no but i think
about it a lot right
so with that what would you what would
you say say years down the line you guys
got married blah blah blah and one of
your homeboys um is like oh what's your
wife's name
and they're like oh my wife's name
stephanie or whatever and you're like
stephanie what what was her surname
before she got married and they're like
oh yo i saw her only fans here's her
picture and everything like what about i
see i see the light dying so that was
that was very unlikely to happen so i
don't really think of that but even if
it did
i would still
be quite secure in the fact that the
pictures
if they're to my in my view not too
not too exposing and her personality as
well if she's classy elegant she you
know our relationship is like respectful
then like cool because how is that
different from any girl you meet at
university who maybe you know is from a
small town in east of england
it's been about you know
i think
pictures
you can sleep with the internet dudes
and google someone's name you're not
gonna know but if someone has a only fan
someone's out on the internet you can
look up their name real quick and be
like oh only fans let me click on it
maybe deactivate it for years it's like
the no shame
like let's bring back shame
oh don't do that you can't judge a woman
no let's let's bring back shame
why a lot of women are in
um their 30s and they they're single um
without without families um it comes
down to again poor decision making um
for for a lot of them um you mentioned
something about
uh having uh morals and and what you
stand for and this this day also i feel
like for um a lot of women um
they don't really
um realize the the consequences to to
their actions and we were discussing
only fans last week and someone said
that um fast money comes with slow
problems
and that's exactly that's exactly what
it is um
whether or not
i'm still on like whether or not you can
have that
so what you guys are saying is a woman
can't be
success successful in your career and
have a family life
that's not true i i'm saying i'm saying
there's trade-offs
okay so you you can't you can be
successful in your career and have a
family life but at what cost who's going
to raise your kids are you going to hire
a nanny who's going to be there when
you're because you can't be successful
and not work long hours
like i i work i work so much making this
podcast happen but my when i have a
family like i'm going to step back i
don't want to do it as much but you
can't have both
um the trade-off i guess you don't have
as much time with with your kids i'm not
but
we've seen that even in
in today's society um
you don't have to i know many um parents
who are not you know extremely
successful but just the demands of the
working lifestyle um especially in
england
demands parents to work longer right and
and longer hours um
but they
i guess it depends on how how how
successful you want to become
um most of the people that i know is yes
they don't want to be
um destitute you know they don't want to
be poor but they want to have a balanced
lifestyle um
for the women
that i know that are career driven
um as much as it pains me to say i have
to agree with you guys when they get to
a point where it's like okay god send me
my man
i want to settle down now
and
it's it's not that you can't work it's
that they don't prioritize a family
yeah and so
and and they think they're better than
guys that make less money than them you
make more money you can date a smaller
percentage like if you want to date
someone that makes more it's a smaller
percentage of guys
yeah if you earn in 100k you will stay
up or yeah
girls want guys that make i want to say
30 at least more than them yeah so if
you're making 100k
now now it's down to 10 of guys and they
think they're better than the guys
making 45k that's the problem
it's not that it's not that the single
childless women can't get a family they
absolutely can but they won't settle
because they've been alpha widowed too
many times in their 20s
what'd you say
don't you think sometimes
this kind of conversation can get a bit
unfair towards the women so for example
sometimes i view it as maybe
it's not just you know these women
making trade-offs that they're not
they're not really considering long-term
impacts or maybe it's lacking
the the men around their age somehow
lacking so we have all these other
things that affect the dating the dating
game like the fertility crisis for men
so men now are like half as fertile as
there were you know uh 20 or 30 years
ago which would impact their behaviors
which should impact the fact that we
have more betas and sims than we had
ages ago back in the day a skinny skinny
nerd scientist would not necessarily
have been a pushover but nowadays those
archetypes those stereotypes are kind of
very much more common and you know
realities so
it isn't like and maybe even in a
conversation for like you know
prioritizing a family
shouldn't
part of the onus be on the man as well
because you know in modern times both
people would have to compromise around
each other well okay so
you're right it does fall on both people
but the problem is women have a
biological clock men don't
you guys could get married at 50 and
still have a whole ass family
we can't necessarily do that
and so we have to make choices quicker
it's not fair but it's just life
we have to make choices and trade-offs
quicker trade-offs quicker than you guys
and the other problem is even on dating
like now we have more honest data on
dating apps on what women want and women
only swipe right like five percent of
the time on dating apps yeah usually the
top twenty percent yeah and yeah and a
hundred percent of women when you ask
them what they want in a man it's twenty
percent of men
so there's just not enough men to go
around so either we die alone or we we
quote unquote settle but it's not
settling it's getting someone on their
level and they don't want to do that and
so that's why you see 50 percent of
women over there over 30 are saying
single and childless
i would agree with your statement on
maybe there's not enough men to go
around yeah so maybe part of the
conversation would be um or you know
we'll be trying to make more males
successful attractive men
as opposed to you know sometimes i feel
like it gets a bit towards like only the
women who made all their mistakes and
it's like maybe guys these days just
kind of are just do you not think the
level for a guy now has to be way way
higher than it was say yeah 50 years ago
100 years ago absolutely and on top of
that would you not also say that um
a lot of a lot of these guys are coming
out more and more feminine because they
think that's what women want
and look at how they're raised and you
know sometimes
no doubts
i'll say that's the case well yeah i
mean i do i do think i will give you i
think there is a growing problem of men
that are addicted to corn
and video games and like that's and now
there's going to be a whole metaverse
like that's a whole nother issue but
what started the problem
was it was it the men or the women
because what you see is an increase in
divorce after the onset of birth control
so it almost seems like it was the women
that started raising their standards
first because as soon as they got the
chance to sleep with the alpha like the
alpha guys
they took it they say 20 percent of men
are raising a kid that's not theirs
it's like that's like the worst that's
the what if the male equivalent of grape
i think a girl should go to jail she
does that but you never hear feminists
talking about that where are the
feminists marching the streets
no no no i'm gonna i'm gonna take a
second i'm gonna read some super chats
um
okay guys just so you know
we have a big campaign going right now
it's called get ish a camera
the goal is to take the money that we
make in june so we have until the end of
june because the way youtube works is it
pays you out by the month so we want to
take this money and get issue camera so
all the super chats are going towards
getting a camera
oh let's get me a camera okay so
um ed boat bro on the left grow some
standards um sentience offs to the
female and the white cap you're doing
exactly what feminism has trained you to
do making excuses it's called
accountability for your choices if women
chose better
chose one they would suffer the cons
consequences for it weak beta
i did not build myself up through my 20s
to settle for an old woman over 30 who's
had ample time to choose a partner
that's there's younger less damaged not
lazid dip pipe feminism has been
constantly a constantly growing tool of
those who are antichrists of a greedy
commercialized world sentience pearl
davis you couldn't get any feminists to
come on the show but there's plenty of
them with beards on here
on the sentience before
she's great
yes
um zentian's 50 super chat
going towards the camera okay the former
male feminist who is still a beta
feminist man i said loosely you are weak
and have no standards only fam has only
fans has guilt by association regardless
of the content your woman will have your
balls and spine it before you smell her
panties the uk the uk economist why
would a high value man want his
competitors in business to see his wife
naked on only fans it'll only affect his
network opportunities in business just
human it's one thing to say let me be or
do what i want it's another thing to say
you should be like this because it'll be
better for everyone lately feminism does
the latter and it's kind of annoying
sentience to the female guests there's
only one emotion most women respond to
and that's the [ __ ] emotion women
respect and desire that strength when
they are fickle as their emotions the
savvy the savvy ninja said
sharing frustration as a man to a woman
is one thing being emotionally
towards the same woman is different i
very much subs subscribe to stoicism
could be a live show topic sometime
genova and antana guy on the right would
you oh would you date your ex again
no no that's a quick no okay
um she's great though
tell her some bro take the l she dumped
you because you were emotional
[Laughter]
sentience um to the female with the
colored shirt in the corner i'm sorry to
the female with the colored shirt in the
corner you have strangers looking at
objectively at your situation and you
were dumped because you showed weakness
sadly you still do no one here buys the
bs of a mutual breakup blaze um she used
the jedi mind trick on him
samuel samuel david um no message just a
super chat appreciate you okay just
human i think feminism is good for
female individuality i don't think
there's anything wrong with a woman
finding out who they are or what they
would like without men involved my issue
is that when they start telling men what
they should like um raw guy name asked
10 dads at my job
they would all rather be broke the rest
of their lives if they if if their own
biological son would become rich in his
honor and cast and contrast to be rich
himself and be fooled into raising a kid
that isn't his and never have his own
delican phlegm feminism inadvertently
gives all the power to the top one
percent of men in time that will be
shown only to the winners
darius um gibson fifty dollar super chat
whoo
get is the camera okay real one i see
feminism is a movement meant for female
liberation and now it has become
weaponized and a finesse movement men
must be traditional while women must be
modern david thompson the leadership for
men in the household is not a license
for tyranny though bad men have used it
in that way feminism over corrected and
destroyed homes we need to fix home
homes and return to jesus
um sylvan slater and i'm trans and
feminism is using the trans community as
a weapon against men to justify man
hating dragon stallion one zero zero one
hedy green in 1900 was titled the
richest woman in america and she was a
wall street financer and businesswoman
she worked her butt off and didn't
demand to have things given to her the
uk economist all those feminists left
ukraine while their men were forced to
stay and die for their nation great
great that equality is working in
ukraine
sentience feminism has greatly helped
helped the men who have their stuff
together to get laid without commitment
i implore most women to follow it while
i invest in their future loneliness via
cat food dog and wine delicious tears
the uk economist look at the communities
where the youth gain but gang violence
is common there's a lack of traditional
family values and two parent homes that
benefit kids
s-t-f-u-f-f-s it takes y'all hours to
decide on food i ain't waiting on a
rub-n-tug for you to make up your effing
mind
baby boomers from world war ii our
grandparents um zentians another 50
dollar super chat
sentience i love you okay um if studies
show corn and its ill effects would
people agree that p work is real work
furthermore since corn and social media
are the same would people consider
social media people the same as p work
on how they affect their brain
s-t-f-u-f-f-s being corn before corn i
had an imagination and it oh that was
the last that was the last one i mean oh
you might want to refresh there's more
we've had yeah
okay they really want to get your camera
huh you have rules i appreciate you you
guys want to know what you guys want to
know what ish looks like
send some money some money yeah put a
one in the chat if you do
yeah one in the chat okay also guys like
the video it is really important that
you guys are liking the video for the
algorithm
um okay derek walker
um dude on the left is regurgitating
everything i've heard my whole life i'm
43 the game's changed and we've got to
adjust or continue living in pain angel
pearl do you realize the claims you make
are very extreme based off of stats
which um you do not provide the source
of but are also wrong which ones um
xernax any any women who desires a
family but doesn't prepare for it like
she would be a doctor is saying it would
be nice if she has a family actions and
behaviors define beliefs if they
conflict change behavior jerome dunbar
what is he going to do with the camera
it's like every time he talks he's going
to yeah you're going to see me every
time yeah yeah i want to be a voice in
the background yeah
what is he going to do with cameron
he's going to be on it like what the
okay josh people talk about
accountability but as soon as grey hat
holds men accountable it's a problem ed
vote bro on the lo oh that we did that
one um and then there's a one dollar
super chat from casman merchant
no no message just a super chat
appreciate you i'm gonna refresh it one
more time guys one more time just to
make sure okay
they said woman in the white hat i'm
looking around i'm like he has a white
hat
today i don't know the stigma with only
fans and americans
i haven't met anyone use this this
application but the reaction is very
strong
okay so question
do you think that women not having
children is part of the reason that
we're on antidepressants
especially because single childless
women over the age of 45 are
ranked the least happy
on top of that antidepressants are
rising in the u.s mostly in women
and women are twice as likely as men to
be on antidepressants
i feel like in general people are
lacking purpose they're being told
things like or having a successful
career or buying a house is going to
make you feel happy and maybe not for
everyone that's going to make them happy
potentially for women biologically
having children is something that's
likely to make them happy so yeah there
could be a link there definitely
i don't think so as much i think i think
there's probably a link but there's also
other things i think anxiety and
depression mental health is becoming
more commonplace yeah those issues are
becoming more common anyway so the
assumption that is because of you know
changing gender roles and family
aesthetics is um i don't think is you
know necessarily accurate
so you think it's just it was always
there it's just coming to the forefront
no i think it's being
exacerbated by social media by
you know the type of foods we eat now by
the kind of social influences we have
now by the fact that charity society's
changed so quickly that you know a lot
of the things that our parents would
have taken kind of
um refuge in like you know the family
structure is almost non-existent and now
people are having to find all these
different ways right to exist and to
find meaning and a lot of them are
failing at that well no i definitely
agree that social media i think is part
of it and i would i would guess probably
obesity too like rising ob yeah of
especially in the u.s
for sure um
but
i i i think women are biologically like
we want to have kids
and i think women end up really unhappy
when we don't
and a lot of times like i've had i've
had girls that said they didn't want
kids and then they found out they were
infertile
and they're devastated
yeah
i think that'd be a savage blow to find
out that kind of stuff and i think
you know speaking on it
i don't i if you speak to any mother i
don't and good mothers i'm talking about
i'm not talking about the exceptions to
that and the other but what i'm saying
here is
most of them will will be like you're
the best thing that's ever happened to
me like i had you you one of the best
things i love you and this and the other
so
i i think it's crazy that there's almost
a narrative being pushed is that the
children's a burden it's uh difficult
like you have a superpower you literally
have the superpower to create life so i
don't understand how you don't
think that's a good thing and i think a
lot of
feminists as well will push this kind of
like if you're not strong and
independent
that you are a failure as a housewife or
as a woman who decides to have children
you're a failure and it's shamed well i
i had a tick tock of my friend um she
she's a housewife
and um i did a video just her talking
about how she got to be in that
situation right and how much she like
loves her husband and it went stupid
viral like joe rogan saw it
because
like
and it's crazy that like she went viral
for literally loving her husband and
being a housewife that's it
yeah
from that i
i was looking at some of the comments
and a lot of women were like oh you
shouldn't um
submit i think the word submissive
is like a
trigger what the
yeah because when women hear submissive
it's like
we think that we have to fall back die
down not be
a woman and pretty much be your slave
but
and i think that that's something that
feminism has like
said like don't be submissive be
independent be strong blah blah but you
can be submissive to your husband and
still be able to
i would say
be a woman it's not like they're taking
away your womanhood side i would say
that submissive well you submit to your
boss you submit to a coach but people
don't think of it like that when it
comes to like certain things like that
um when it comes to like relationship
between a man and a woman submissive is
just like oh no never what were you
gonna say um do you think it's possible
to have a fulfilling life without
kids because if we're gonna go on the
premise that we're not upset because
they can't have so do you think women
i think i think it can be a lot of fun
while you're still hot and young
and as women i don't think we understand
the amount of like typically the amount
of attention that we get
and just like benefits in the world by
being young and pretty
but
you know it's it's a different tune at
45.
55 alone yeah cats
55 and by yourself no family
and remember you're a man so you're
thinking of it from a man's perspective
as a man that's not really a problem
because most men are okay being alone
women are different
i think
community right like maybe maybe because
i think that may well be an issue that
as humans we have to face more and more
often is that you know you can't
everyone can't have kids all the time
right you can't manage your population
right like that if everyone felt like
yeah i'm here afraid of going down right
now it's a massive issue that's that's
natural though because everything is
expensive so why do you have loads of
kids well then why do then why does the
lower income population have more
children if they make more money they
have less kids yeah it's a club
what do you mean it's a class thing
involved it's like you know
educated
informed people tend to make more
educated informed decisions and so
but that's the scariest child right and
so they would have less children as
opposed to uneducated people who would
but you would think that people who make
more money would have the majority of
kids because they can't afford them and
the people who don't have money would
have less kids because they can't afford
them yes it's not what's happening but i
i just don't think it's sustainable if
if if we carry on with kind of the
traditional mindset of like yeah
everyone should have firstly i don't
think everyone should have kids i think
there are a lot of people who aren't
developed enough as human beings to have
kids and i think one thing that's
overlooked with the you know traditional
family narrative
um
traditional family structure narrative
is that you know everyone had kids and
everyone was all happy but you know you
had these issues with women who were
you know incredibly underutilized and
unfulfilled in their roles people had to
be really boxed in
for the traditional way of life to be
feasible and now you have more freedom
as a natural consequence you have less
kids
i i just don't really see how
it could be
everyone that's out so what do you mean
when you said they were boxed in
because we just talked about a self-made
millionaire in the 1900s yeah a woman
who did that how are we boxed
and in so you could name like a female
millionaire but that that would be kind
of
um
an example that is outside of the norm
right it's not the norm um but you could
do it if you wanted to do it because she
did it
so not what's really holding what what's
holding us back
or is it the norm in society in general
anyway yeah even as a man i don't know
i'm saying at that time that's not the
norm
and so and like i i would say the
biggest thing that was holding women
holding women back is like birth control
like yeah they get they get knocked up
how many of our grandparents had shotgun
weddings
but even even just the the ideas that
were common at the time like people
feeling like say what ideas so say to
get rich in that woman's role i don't
know anything about this woman but let's
say let's say she had to get a good job
and then have the opportunity to make
even more money
then access to that good job would have
been kind of the the key to her her
success maybe
in those times maybe women didn't
actually do those kind of jobs and so
she would have made
been turned down purely because of being
a woman maybe she would have been less
likely to be
supported and motivated and pushed
towards reaching that potential
um
you can't deny that in the past there
was all these kind of boxes that people
had to fill in both men and women i was
i would say there was more consequences
where women had to face the consequences
of their own actions
so like we couldn't vote right but that
came with being drafted that was a
consequence so more freedom comes with
more responsibility
and it's the same thing with birth
control so back then if if most people
were sexually active quite young like
before the average age of first marriage
now was 27. i don't i don't know when
people had sex there but like
you get pregnant like that's a
consequence so now we're taking away the
consequences for women
and also most most uh millionaires are
self-made they're not employed into into
it so that's one of the biggest factors
as well is that they're self-made that
really is yeah most millionaires are
self-made i read that it was most most
wealth was inherited
no
it's not true
okay i have to look into that but i read
that the vast majority of wealth is
inherited the idea that but with those
inheritance like where did
where did it come from did it come from
someone working a lot
um
at a business that they were hired at or
did it come from them being self-made
it came from parents that was that's
what i'm saying what did the parents do
for them to inherit 88 of all
millionaires are self-made
in which country 88
um that's in the u.s 88 are self-made
yeah and the us has the majority of
millionaires and billionaires that is
true what likes like so they weren't
millionaires and then they became purely
through their own actions i mean yeah
that's like that's what my dad did
he was he was born one of 13 kids in the
south side of chicago they like all
shared rooms they're very poor yeah and
then he just worked 80 hours a week my
whole life people don't understand what
goes into being a millionaire like i
i barely saw him growing up to be honest
great guy love my dad i get to see him
all i want now but like most people men
and women don't want to work 80 hours a
week for 40 years
was your mother stay at home mom um no
she helped him build his business so
they like worked on it together we they
had 10 kids
so in in in building this business they
made 10 kids yeah i mean like don't give
me there's trade-offs like that's what
like that's what i'm saying life is
about trade-offs so even with them like
we had nannies they helped us
like there was times where i didn't see
my parents i guess you could afford to
have nannies as well yeah at that point
not when we started that when they
started
yeah i just feel like
because you mentioned something
about um a woman has and i'm very like
um
i hold back a lot when i'm speaking this
because i don't think um as a man i have
um
how much how much right to speak on a
woman or woman's body but when you said
a woman has this superpower
to um to to
to create life essentially
um
[Music]
do you feel like because you have this
superpower that you must use it
and if you don't use it is it a bad
thing
it's a waste
it's a waste but okay
but is it your
like is it is it your fault that you've
been given this superpower
and
it's almost like you expected to do
something with it what if you don't want
to do something with it then there's a
waste you don't get wrong there's no
expectation on you or there is an
expectation on you but like but how is
that fair
life isn't life isn't fair it's a waste
it's a waste but what do you like
yeah it's like being given a million
dollars and then you decide to throw it
away
it's a waste
i mean
good good parents will tell you their
kids is the like the best thing that's
ever happened to them well
no not all not every parent right
because you can you can be a good parent
and have a bad kid and you'll probably
regret where do you live but you're
looking at exceptions rather would you
say most parents would say their kids
are the best things that that have ever
happened to them and their life is more
fulfilled by having kids depends where
you wouldn't say by and large we're
going to look for the exception
um well i don't know it's hard to say
because it depends
would you not say having another
having a legacy and having
grandkids great grandkids potentially
like if you have you're in good health
or something like that having
just so many beings coming from you and
you created all this life
like your your employer doesn't give a
single [ __ ] about you so
your people want to pursue the career
and this that and the other fair enough
if that's if that's what you want unless
you don't want kids you never want your
kids and stuff like that but how much of
it's programmed and how much of its
the
you know the people just listening to to
what's going on and and then
and how much is it trauma i've heard so
many people say they don't want to have
kids because they're afraid they can't
raise them
because they're maybe their parents
weren't great or maybe they had bad
relationship after bad relationship and
they don't feel like they can find
someone that they actually love and want
to start a family with i respect that so
much because i definitely
i'm nigerian right
and so part of this traditional mindset
it's common in nigeria people just have
we had a driver
my dad's in politics so you have all
these drivers people you know to drive
you around and this guy had like nine
kids and he'll be asking for like a
raise every couple months but i gotta
feed these kids that's illogical this is
a this is an uneducated man in like some
town in nigeria you use it like our show
like if we fired him that's like 12
people who are in deep poverty
like like and these are kids that i know
you're not talking to you don't who has
the time to raise 12 reasonably
kind of well-rounded human beings when
you're just one person and you've got a
job
so that's that's what my that's what my
dad's family did yeah that's an
exception right you became a millionaire
not really in irish catholics they
always had big families that's what i'm
saying like
why why is it just because they're poor
like are they less valuable because it
comes with poverty as well it's poverty
yeah it's not it's not just because
they're poor but with with for example
that example i can relate to that i'm
i'm congolese and we have much of the
same thing like
even till
today
2022 i have
um uncles who are
making babies at crazy rape but you
can't
find the means to to defeat you
um
kids everywhere
yeah he has because but again
i think because of he he's not well
educated himself now he's making all
these
all these human beings and he's not able
he's he's a drunk right he's not able to
to um to be a great um
uh
male role model for them now i'm
i have to agree because
even working um
in the youth sector
you see that a lot and of a lot of the
young people that i work with i kind of
feel sorry for them because it's like
they've been birthed and they've been
put into this world without
um
the right support you could argue that
these are
are few and far in between and the
majority of people come from
um i don't know stable households where
they can afford you know to have a
decent i mean you should be married
before you have a child
so like i agree with you you should be
married before you have a child
that is if he's like you know getting
girls pregnant left and right that's not
conducive for a family
no
the scary part you're also saying and
this is a big problem as well is that a
lot of higher iq individuals are not
having kids and usually it's because
they're thinking oh i need to make a
financial decision about this they said
the other and very loads and loads of
low iq individuals are having loads of
kids which then has a population they
have more time though
and they have more time to have food
like the birth rate is declining like
where our population is at least in the
us it's getting smaller and smaller
which is it which isn't good for an
economy
everywhere same with nigeria there's
people who you know can't like a lot of
people who are saying i won't have kids
which is like really weird for nigeria
given like you know people aren't using
protection
yeah because because they've gone out
with like 15 siblings in like a shack in
somewhere and then to what they're
saying that they don't want to have they
don't want to have their because of that
experience yeah i think it's a natural
progression of like society and people's
mentality in my view to have kids you
have to be somewhat qualified you know i
don't think it's like everyone's got a
superpower everyone should use it and
the biggest thing you can do is it's
like no have a plan get married you know
be qualified be well-rounded you know
stable individuals and then make the
decision i agree with you not everyone
can do that though i think most people
can if women can what the hell if you
make the right decisions as a woman
every girl can have a child oh come on
you're telling me a girl that's 120
i don't even care she could be a four if
she gets a good body mary's young she
can marry rich and be a housewife what
do you mean every girl can reproduce
yeah men swipe right 50 of the time on
dating apps yeah yeah like
yeah but but girl yeah she's going so
one in two chance yeah
and and honestly the girls that are
getting swiped left on if they lost 50
pounds they'd probably be in the right
category yeah so like based on looks and
then there's like being a well-rounded
person then there's come on come on
yeah
guys guys are not like
we we we know what we want we want
attractive women right yeah attractive
feminine women typically but i'm talking
about like mindful mindfully creating a
child not just like oh yeah
okay like we agree we agree get married
first get married first but i'm saying
every girl has the opportunity if she
wants to get married it might not be to
the guy she wants maybe maybe she wants
a guy that's out of her league but men
are swiping right 50 of the time if
she's not getting swiped right on lose
50 pounds i'm sure the guys will swipe
right on you then wow yeah
you're right
can i just ask some the demand the guys
a question
do you do you want a housewife no
do you want a housewife yeah why not
see
one thing for yourself
you want a housewife
uh
no
why
because
the kind of life that i live and i'm
gonna lead i need well because the thing
is the reason i say no is because
traditionally housewives are they're
seen as um
uh unintelligent there's they're seen as
in the west in the west
in the west yeah
are you talking about wags like
footballers wives famous oh no i don't
want that yeah but then i'm just trying
to understand what you where you think
no i don't well okay from my experiences
um
what should i say from my background uh
when you talk about a housewife
um and then i don't even feel like this
is they are incapable of
of doing more but they just feel like
they are obligated to
to do that black but if i take if i take
um my my mother for example yeah she's
she's the most amazing woman i've ever
met i don't i really don't know how she
manages to do everything that she does
but um
she's she's a very um successful and
biomedical scientist
um author and businesswoman
um
but
with a lot of
young girls especially they say to her
that what we don't understand how
you're able to do what you have done
like you you went you prioritized
your career
and you've done well for yourself but
you still
had children okay i know how she did it
she took she took gaps she took gaps
like yeah she took gaps um
um she had like every child every like
nine years or so yeah i'm not i'm not
saying every girl should be a housewife
that's a luck that's a luxury most girls
don't get to be a
there's housewife what's the opposite of
a housewife a modern woman yeah there's
like
a career-driven surrogate mother you
know like yeah but do you not think like
it would also motivate you as a man to
make more money to have a housewife well
oh so if i mess up we're all done
no but like it was so interesting when
you said about um the guy in nigeria and
he had like he was trying to feed his
family like and you you put a negative
spin which is fair enough but i looked
at and i went this guy's hustling for
his kids like he's out here asking for a
raise
every however many months it is to feed
his family and what happens is one of
them kids is gonna be successful out of
ten what they're all gonna be bombs
nah there's gonna be one that's gonna go
i'm gonna change my life for someone and
like you might be successful but turn
out to be a [ __ ] person
because why is that your like why is
that your default
why is that no because
if you think about it logically um
if he if he has say it's a boy for
example all right can't we talk about
about the girls too much but say it's a
boy right and um
he's his dad is always out working his
dad's not there he might see a great
example like wow my dad's a hustler he's
making it all of that but he's gonna be
missing something in him because he's
because his father wasn't there to teach
him certain lessons and i'm seeing that
i'm seeing that today fair pray he can
he can turn out to be you know a
billionaire a great person but
but he could be the trader he could also
be a great person yeah
so why why he could but that's very
unlikely it's unlikely
it's unlikely
what evidence do you have to support
that it's unlikely yeah what evidence
does that mean
one at a time but i'll give you an
example my dad was gone all the time all
of my siblings make six figures and
they're all very nice people
we'd adopted three children that weren't
ours my parents my family's like very
very kind and your family okay
that's what i'm saying i don't think
it's an exception because we know a lot
of families very similar where the where
the dad works a lot this is very common
where i'm from i'm saying it from the
point where
i've lived in london i've grew up in
london i've grew up in
uh
some of the poorest parks in london
that's where i'm looking from i've seen
dads who are trying to be good dads and
there's nothing wrong with that trying
to be a good like good dad and
but i just feel like with a lot of men
were programmed to to feel like okay i'm
gonna go out there i'm gonna make the
money i'm gonna make like i'm gonna
bring the money home and that's it i'm a
great dad you know where there's more to
it and especially as a boy you require
more from your father fair play that
they might be successful but then
they're going to grow up to be a certain
kind of i see where you're coming from
right you see i can understand what
you're saying i wouldn't necessarily say
that he might turn out as a bad person
but i can
say that he may grow up to be a great
person but there may be things that he's
lacking from his adolescent that his
father needed to add or whoever it is
that now as an adult they have to deal
with that lack and
work through it understand it like you
had to do with whatever situation you
had happened
in your adolescence and you had to work
through it and process it i've done the
work if he doesn't do the work he's
going to have kids
and he's going to then pass that on
you know what i mean so like what i'm
trying to like all i'm trying to say is
um well tim that's what everyone else is
saying it's great you have the options
there but we need to understand what
you're giving up like what the trade-off
is you have nine kids you're working
you're hustling it's great but i think
that's a great father who who's hustling
for his children yeah and like what
you're like the the trade-off is he's
gone a lot i'm not saying that i'm not
i'm not faulting him for for going out
and then go to war and yeah no no i'm
not i'm not voting i'm not faulting the
men that that do that like even
historically men weren't around
like that
would you say uh just a quick question
would you say that
that's coming from the lens of london
one of the most expensive cities in the
world because obviously you know there
are societies that you may be able to
move to or the suburbs or something like
that where you might be able to
stimulate that that big family and make
it affordable
historically this doesn't make sense
because 8 000 years ago 17 women
reproduced for one man you're telling me
everyone that is alive today is
emotionally damaged historically
like yeah 17 women reproduced for every
one man well the dad's going to be
around for 17 kids
no i'm not saying i'm not saying that he
he
he has to be always shouldn't be what
i'm saying is understanding like what
because we're talking about the
trade-offs understanding what the
trade-off is
but your default is like oh they're
going to be bad people
but historically 17 men or 17 women
reproduced for every one man so
historically is everyone a bad person
that was your default i feel like we all
have um
things in us that we can always develop
and depending on our upbringing and
where we grew up and the kind of people
that we were around for a lot of us were
around our parents
um
but if you lack that
then
the chances are that you're not going to
be as self-developed as you have to be
and then you're going to take that and
then produce another kid
that make them bad people
it doesn't necessarily make them bad
but it can make them bad well you're
kind of asking people depending on the
choices that they make through that see
someone like myself
going through certain traumas that i
then had to do the work to do i could
have taken those traumas and
and do what a lot of
other young people do
as a as a result of of dealing with that
so
uh but this just doesn't make sense like
because his story like historically
like what you're saying doesn't match up
to history
you know what i'm saying like if 17 men
or women reproduced for every one guy
the guy wasn't around that much
which indicates but people still
reproduced and they still continued to
make kids and the population got better
and better and better
so so that premise it just doesn't make
sense i wouldn't necessarily
say that it
never mind
but i do think that i understand what
you're saying when it comes to
when
men work a lot or when men aren't
there necessarily as much as they need
to be that it may not affect the
majority but it has an effect on kids
because
there i think there is a need for
men
in the home
because we've seen with
just different scenarios that
it
there's there's an effect either he's
going to be there he's not there he's
going to be there a lot or not a lot and
it has some effect whether it's big or
small but there's a difference between a
guy the dad not being in the home and
the dan work dad working a lot yeah
there's a difference but it's still
they're still in effect that's what i'm
saying i'm not saying that's like a big
effect i'll say that that's not as much
my sticking point with what you said
about the the driver yeah and having
nine kids
to me the sticking points were a couple
of things firstly
he didn't have the means himself to
actually increase your standard of
living he depended on us to do that so
really you could make a really strong
argument that he didn't have the ability
to really provide for these kids within
his own control which is important isn't
that what a job is supposed to do
so but the fact is you're in an
underdeveloped country
and you're having lots of kids for
whatever reason no birth control you and
then you're expecting this isn't like
some highly developed capitalist economy
where like you can like
ladder your way to another another
driving role with another guy and get
double pay and then you can start you're
not going to do that it's nigeria mate
it's not going to happen so first and
his kids will have to suffer for that
right and another thing is for me it's
the fact that
so
he doesn't have time to
make to spend
in developing those kids which i think
is important like i get that yeah you
you can't have kids
like it was funny that you said you know
one of them could be great but i think
in nigeria how you likely that do you
think military men or bad dads who go to
war and are gone for years at a time
they're absent dads which is what's
factual bad is like subjective
but i would say that they're definitely
absent i think so even they wouldn't say
that like it was bad i wasn't around you
know they even they were you'd say like
in a way they're bad dads no they're
absent dads okay being bad is subjective
right depends on what you do when you're
actually there how you set up your home
to support those kids in your absence
but if you just have kids and you're
just away for like half of the year then
you know it's not looking too good but i
can't comment on individual and
individuals you know but i hope we agree
that like it would be better for these
guys to be with their kids right and
they will be there i mean we're assuming
that the kids actually want to spend
loads of time with their dad when the
modern kid wants to play fortnite all
the time
but the the point is that it's the
automatically like assuming there that
there's a negative outcome of the dad's
working all the time like i hear it in
the way you guys are talking about it
yeah it's like it's like very it's odd
to me
you don't think
it's like contagious to have both
parents around i think it's very
advantageous and advantageous to have
both parents around but i think dads
should be working and i think it's
admirable that a guy's
is trying to provide for 13 children i
think that's amazing
i i so
i'm not saying it was it was one woman
or these like baby mamas everywhere one
woman wow like that's that's beautiful i
assume i didn't yeah but what kind of
what's what cost does he okay is well
put in here poor kids they're
are they less valuable
no no it's not nevertheless
well i don't know but my my point is
yeah it's okay we're applauding him that
is admirable that you know
like great he's got these 13 kids with
this one woman and he's you know trying
to make a living for all of that but i
bet you the brother is tired i bet you
mentally that's his own fault
which makes it more admirable
and also he's spreading his seed which
is what he we are biologically
predisposed to do
he's doing what men
he's doing what men's us are supposed to
do yeah but yeah he's feeling
tired he's feeling drained he's uh
he's he's emotionally what you don't
agree with me was even entirely drained
so you said you're dealing with so do
you think men who don't have kids are
like not not spreading you know you
don't think that kids see that their dad
works hard and they respect it and they
look up to it like i think being a good
role model is good as above all else
yeah we're not saying that there's no
respect
it's it's more like
you should
try and set up a life that would allow
you to spend a reasonable amount of time
supporting your kids and you know
emotionally xyz that doesn't mean he's
not working why if he just wants to have
as many kids as possible and he can
support him
well he couldn't
that's why he was hustling so much and
if he's hustling to support him if
that's what he wants to do and then and
then he's going to outrage nine kids who
barely have enough to get by they're
going to go into society and be armed
robbers and this and that
they see we're going back to it that is
your automatic assumption is that just
because they're poor they're going to be
armed robbers i'm talking about the
context of nigeria so in this country
you've had a lot of kids who are under
underfunded right they're
under-supported the statistics show that
it's highly likely you're not going to
be end up adopting two parent homes in
two parent homes no this
i i would i would i think i would i
would i would love to see this statistic
of in two parent homes
so let me get this straight that work a
lot
so you're saying right so if if
we double the amount of people that have
like a lot of kids you're saying that
wouldn't have any impact in
number of in the rate of crime or i
would people i would guess not if
they're in two parent homes
if they are married in two parent homes
do you know how they are they are
productive functioning members of
society but that's hard to do
it's really it's really it's really not
that hard to do to get married
before you have a child that's actually
pretty easy yeah but common people are
not doing that yeah okay because
it's difficult right
no because people are make poor choices
and and oftentimes they're bailed out
and the government funds those poor
choices like we're giving money the
money to single mothers we're funding
that lifestyle we're funding
single-parent homes
literally
that's one of the biggest issues as well
a lot a lot of criminals a lot of uh you
know psychological issues come from
single parents you would see a decrease
if people faced consequences for their
actions
but we're always bailed out like that's
the whole thing with feminism where
women are bailed out for every bad
decision they make
it depends it depends on your ideology
right you could come up from the
ideology of like you know as as you
put it he will have nine kids and maybe
one of them turns out to be well you
could look at people as like numbers
right you know maybe one does all right
that's okay to have nine whole human
beings who may have all these issues
being malnourished they've been abused
this one got stuck here this got some
weird issue but one of them is all right
like why is that your default
of nigeria and and
and and when it's coming from i'll use
i'll use developing countries developing
countries right right right an island or
50 years ago right maybe you could have
these massive nucleophiles most of human
history
it doesn't mean everyone was murdering
and robbed like
the one thing i will say that like most
of human history everyone was in poverty
people find people even even i'm sorry
one more point then i'll let you go even
even poor people today are rich on a
historical perspective even the poorest
of people are rich
yeah if we go by all of history yeah go
ahead
so one thing i will say is that you'll
find that within the struggle that
people go through
they find strength courage they find
resilience so when people are going
through tough times
you'll find that it builds character
so when you say like the default is
they're going to be robbers they're
going to be stealing they're going to be
doing all of these things i just feel
like that doesn't really
come in that doesn't come to play like
that that's true but i can give people
like bad mental health issues as well
people like kill themselves so like it
can go either way um if you don't have
the right people around him yeah and i
don't think
struggle always leads to a better
character there's a curve right there's
a there's a point where like some some
challenges and obstacles
may build character but there's a point
where it's like
if the benefits are lacking now now
you're actually being beaten down and we
want in my opinion we want a society
where the maximum amount of people allow
the maximum opportunity to develop
themselves to the highest level and that
would mean having kids but the reality
of it is that's really almost impossible
to do especially now maybe 50 years ago
when you could you know support a family
on one salary and it was like one dollar
a week and your kids didn't need
therapists or like you know anything and
the food was decent and they had
community but you don't have that now
you have tick-tock in
so in 2022 we have a higher standard of
living than ever in human history
relative in some ways in some way like
you could go from before when
like even people that are marked as poor
in the west they have air conditioning
and tvs
yeah but in other ways they they're also
underserved
how like community like you mentioned i
think like we're very lacking in
community nowadays and i think that's
due to social media due to like maybe
this capitalism and these big cities of
like pushing people into like quite
individualistic like lifestyles so i
think community is something that people
really need to work on because that
helps to raise kids as well like some
kids are not raised there's that saying
isn't their kids are raised by a
community or something like this yeah
it's really true
as well i feel like now
our culture that used to have certain
inbuilt values like you know honesty
virtue is kind of been overtaken by
internet culture right we all share
memes so part of this gender issue is
that everyone's getting this idea from
the internet that we can be everything
and it's not necessarily possible and
then there's also food food is less
nutritious now than it was years ago
there's also pollution air pollution
especially in the underground in london
causes brain inflammation that could
lead that is well they used to have
horses everywhere and like like the cow
poop or the horse poop was everywhere
and that was really bad for cities with
pollution
but there's a few points that have been
made like one about community and the
other about kind of um like social
interaction but does that not even start
off in the family context anyway so like
to learn those skills and stuff like
that is usually within a family context
but if you're just a single single kid
in a single parent family how are you
gonna of course you're gonna be so
socially awkward of course you're gonna
have social social issues because you're
you're kind of can you don't have
brothers and sisters to interact with
you don't have people to to interact
with from a very young age and learn
those social skills but even if you did
have all those even if you were in a
two-person family you'd still have to
deal with the consequences of modern
reality and that the environment that's
raising you is completely different to
what would have raised
you know
people 20 or 30 years ago that has
serious impacts on mental health or
trajectory as we've just been discussing
right there's levels of practicality
that like you can't you can't live this
you can't have a kid at 18. now that
makes no sense you're basically
a child it's weird you're going to be so
good the government's supporting half
these individuals anyway so i i don't
agree with you but do they do these
individuals have
the the
have the know-how of how to raise this
kid in this the most most 18 year olds
are still banging out well that's why um
playstation and one and that's why you
should wait yeah it's been amazing until
and and i agree with you i'll give the
example of um
of of steve harvey right if you'd like
to speak about him um
he he he had a six this segment on his
on his show where he had all his kids
come and he was basically crying on
camera and he broke down because he he
apologized to his kids saying that um i
was absent no it's a great father this
guy has been hustling you know he said
he said that um
i wasn't there because um i was i was
working hard to support you guys you
know which which is admirable but um he
he
yeah he broke down because he knew that
somewhere somehow
he's kid he it left a hole in them so
perhaps if he had a better
um
work balance he would have been able to
to
to provide more form for for his kids
not just financially and that's just
steve harvey if i take my own father as
an example greatest man i know hardest
working man i know um
he for a lot of the time especially now
he's not at home he's working but he he
has to work um
out of the city and he comes back the
weekends
now when i was growing up he was still
working working very very hard but at
least at night he will come home and
maybe for five minutes we can have a
conversation that was a lot for me i'm
feeling it for my for my younger
siblings who
are growing up and i'm seeing
i'm seeing the the
the pros and cons of it because they're
growing up with a distant different kind
of discipline that i grew up with so i'm
just thinking to myself in the future
how is that then going to affect them
they're going to be very successful like
they're very very intelligent kids
they're going to be very very successful
on their own but
is that enough
is being successful financially
successful and career successful is that
enough no
is is it enough is it enough yeah
is it enough for what
is it enough for you to
um
[Music]
to feel as if you're in a position
to to have children because you can
afford to have children but you don't
have you don't have the time
to nurture these children you don't have
um
so because you can't give them like a
perfect upbringing
you shouldn't have kids
if you can't if you can't give them
money and be there like life is about
trade-offs and isn't it
one argument i make is like
i i could have had my dad there more
or i could have college debt today i
will take no college debt
no i'm serious life's about trade-offs
okay and so like i
like why why why is it so
i don't i don't know if it
is the same amongst all different
cultures but i know from
just
from a african-american standpoint in
the states i know that if
there was
more
i'll say more men in the household that
it would be
there would be different different
things within the community so i don't
know if it's the same but the issue with
that is that they're not getting married
first before having a kid yeah and in
the u.s black women are the least
married one out of four will ever get
married
and so just to just go off of like just
him saying that
the presence of a father in a household
will have an impact i can understand
that but also
there's a fact that a lot of
um a lot of people in the black
community either aren't married or
they're single parents and so
um okay so up next question since we
were talking about kids do you guys
think that feminism abortion should be
included in feminism do you think that's
something we should be fighting for
yeah hopefully
no because if women didn't have the
option to abort a kid i think a lot of
women would
think about who they're having sex with
and be more
protective of
what
like to protect themselves from not
having kids i think that more women
would be more cautioned i think more
maybe more men would be more cautious
and where they shoot up the club at but
i think it just people would think more
because a consequence like a consequence
an answer for their action is being
taken away okay what do you think so
what was the question um do you think
women should have the right to choose
um is that something feminism should be
fighting to keep
um
[Music]
i think
similar to to what jessa said it's
i don't know
personally i don't know if i can say
they have the right or not
to choose um
i just feel like
more people should be aware of
that their actions and if i mean there's
so many preventative measures now
so
if
if that wasn't there
more people would would be aware
of who they sleep with and
um what will happen as a result of it
okay what do you think
um i feel like people should be able to
choose yeah
but i get the point that people need to
be more self-reflective
because this is i can see what i can see
why people don't like the idea of
abortion from like a religious point of
view even from just a moral point of
view i get it
but there should be the choice but there
shouldn't be loads of abortions
happening that makes no sense people
need to really think about their
decisions but it should be a choice
though so question do you think men
should be able to have a financial
abortion
since women have the right to choose
whether or not we can be a mother should
ben be able to choose if they could be a
father equality yes what does that mean
i don't know what you said so so okay so
when i if i got pregnant today right
yeah then i get to choose to keep it or
abort it yeah the man that got me
pregnant he doesn't get to choose
whether i keep it or abort it but if i
have the baby he's stuck on child
support for 18 years if i don't stay
with him should he have the right while
i'm pregnant to say you know what i
don't want to be a dad i just want to
sign off my rights i don't want to be
liable for child support
i mean again i get it i get why the guy
would think
would maybe say to the woman i want you
to abort it i don't want a kid and then
she carries the kids and it's annoying
it's like long for him but it's still he
still
did the thing right so it's still partly
his responsibility right it's but
wouldn't you say it's her responsibility
too because she did the thing
so it is but it's just one of those
unfortunate things in life like
it's down to the woman isn't it because
it's in her body so it's just the fact
of life that it's going to be her
decision not the guy's decision right
but shouldn't his wallet his decision
no because he did make the decision with
her to have sex yeah but she made the
decision with him to have sex so she
gets a choice so shouldn't shouldn't it
be equal where he made the decision and
she made the decision and they both get
a choice
so his choice would be to not pay any
money for that kids and not be involved
and just say you know what i if it was
up to me we'd abort it she doesn't want
to so i'm just not going to be on the
hook for child support
but wouldn't that cost them being picked
up by the state wouldn't that cost be
picked up by the state
yeah how
as in if the guy's not going to pay
money then where's the money going to
come from for the kids well personally
if it was up if it was pearl's world i
don't think single mothers should be
bailed out at all so
no i mean you should pay pick that up
get married before you carry
get married before you carry
get married before you carry that's
[ __ ] up so i got it and plus the
majority of abortions actually aren't
from low income people it's actually
from people of higher income yeah that's
people making bad decisions then yeah
i got a good story about this
i know a woman who was 37 and she was
talking to a friend of mine
and she was saying you know you can just
if you want to get a kid just just get
knocked up with a random guy just you
know the one choose whatever guy and she
got knocked up she got she got locked up
the guy didn't want it and he was like i
don't want any responsibility with it
and she's like i don't care i'm having
it that's the way it is
so is that not very abusive in nature
but did he know that there was a
possibility she could get pregnant
because if she outright when you have
sex
if she's on protection then
she could have liked it yeah i'm saying
that's not okay that's not okay lying is
yeah but i'm saying i'm saying even like
like she legally could lie to him and
and she's like that yeah but this is
what i'm going back to we're
incentivized to bad behavior is
incentivized because of feminism
so like that's why why do you think that
girl was stealing drake's freaking
condom drake did everything right you
don't think that corn star that got his
kid did the same thing that stuff was
bad
so a guy could do in that case he did
everything right what more could he do
wear a condom
and she could steal the steal the his
his seed
put it up there get pregnant and he's on
the hook for 18 years and in the u.s he
gets 25 percent of that man's income
every year
as well actually 25 of the revenues
athletes get done yeah but they're not
responsible it's not fair so don't
that's different i think maybe they
would never know how she got pregnant so
don't you think they should just be able
to get the same rights that women get
i think that situation where the woman's
deceitful that's a different situation
he would never know
like if the average guy that happens to
he he's never gonna know that she did
that
all he knows is that she's pregnant so
don't you think we have a moral
obligation from a or don't we don't we
have a legal person
a legal
we should legally protect those men
and give them the same right that women
get i think if it's like literally
stealing a bodily fluid to make yourself
pregnant then there should be some kind
of legal thing involved there that makes
sense okay but you don't think that men
should get the same right that women get
to choose not to be a father again it's
like
women are the ones that have to carry
the kids so that's kind of unfair in
general so i feel like some things in
life are not fair and that's one of
those things that's not fair
you have responsibility over whether you
get pregnant or not
but i'm just saying
i don't think men envy women for having
to carry a kid for nine months so that's
an inequality that's always going to be
present just like maybe this situation
for my opinion but you you you're a
woman and you know that this thing can
happen to you right so you consciously
you make the decision to sleep with the
guy and you know that okay for lack of a
better use you are at a disadvantage
because if anything happens you're gonna
have to carry it so yeah you do it
anyways you get pregnant and then why
why do i have to have to suffer
and plus it's i think it's 100 the
girl's fault if she gets pregnant it's a
hundred percent the girl's fault because
you have the opportunity to get an iud
you can get them birth control you can
make the men that sleep with you wear a
condom because as long as there's no
essay you you get to pick who gets to
sleep with you
on top of that you can do adoption on
top of that you can get an abortion so
we have choice choice choice choice
choice men only have one choice then
they can even do that and the girl can
still steal it and have the same outcome
yeah i mentioned the stealing there
should be something legal involved but
if it's like you have a sexual sex and
then like the condom breaks for example
like it's not anyone's fault and then
she gets pregnant then that you still
got the morning after pill now i forgot
you're right morning after pill or maybe
not split so maybe they just get she
gets pregnant like randomly and doesn't
like nobody is it random they were
trying to
is it random
it's a great area so she made a choice
to to sleep with someone she shouldn't
have slept with
and then she made a choice not to go on
birth control
and then she made a choice not to take
the morning after pill
and then she made a choice not to get an
abortion
and then she carries the kid and makes a
choice not to give it up for adoption
sounds like a lot of choices and the man
can't get can't get one
i feel like again it's just one of those
things that there isn't a perfect
solution to it and in this case bring
about mel birth control come on i think
i think the perfect solution is to let
men get a financial abortion
that's your opinion i think i disagree
with that okay what do you guys think
i mean pro-life pro-choice
no i'm not really like try corn or
anything like that so
uh
yeah
yeah this is this this is a tough one i
i'm kind of like people should have
there should be more rights for men if
they want to oblige out of uh
having a kid and i do believe that it's
the responsibility of the woman to who's
having that kid you have so many
different choices to to be able to do
that and i think a guy should be able to
financially what's the word financially
about is that what yeah
financially abort if if he if he wants
to
and that being said uh
i think guys should encourage men to
take responsibility and kind of raise
that kid
but
if they don't want it they don't want to
and if they should have that right to be
able to because that's equality right
i mean i think men should take care of
the kids they have like absolutely
but i don't think they should be on the
hook i don't think she should get a
lifestyle out of it you can get a job
just like you can what are you what are
you you can't work just because you had
a child
and employees are much more facilitating
like sometimes i think girls are just
lazy like they don't want to get a job
is it no i'm serious what is i mean i
get it you have to carry the kid but
after that
you get like
yeah but like you know when people give
birth they lose a lot of like vitality
and energy right and we'll cook all
these issues with your spine but it's a
choice
it's your choice
i'm not talking about the choice i'm
just saying like you know if someone
says i've just given birth to like a kid
this kid weighed like three did you not
hear what i said i said six months she
can you know chill okay okay and then go
get a job it's not like you're making
excuses for these i don't know
why are we making excuses for them
pregnancies looks looks very challenging
so i could understand it
if someone doesn't come out of that as
as sprightly and you know
with the same vitality get the same body
they had when they were you know 21
years old yeah but i just i don't think
she's entitled to his money no you're
not entitled to have it like him pay for
your lifestyle yeah so my view on this
is very like
straightforward right
pro-choice but that has to come with the
financial abortion right so everyone has
maximum freedom right you can you can
choose to have a kid you can choose not
to have a kid i can choose to support a
kid i can choose not to support a kid i
think that's the only rational way of
approaching this
you know the other way
if you force people to you know not
how they use their bodies then you have
to go down a really kind of dodgy slope
of
when when's too far
you know how much can i get you to do
with your body
um so yeah
once too far when you're infringing on
someone else's body
which is the kid
did you know 40 of abortions the woman's
had um one or two abortions in the past
in the u.s
in the u.s yes it's usually the stats
are pretty similar but they don't have
as much data here i don't know i feel
like the u.s is very the culture is very
different i would it's i think it's a
lot more hypergamous i think there's a
lot i think yeah really because um here
like typically what i see is um
the average age of first marriage is
like how westernized a country is and
the the average so if it's younger it's
typically more traditional and if it's
more western um it's usually older and
here the average age of first marriage
is 31 and the average age in the us is
27.
yeah much much longer here but
um
do you think that women are using this
as a form of birth control in a way i
was gonna say yeah i was gonna ask that
question is is it because they've made a
poor decision on the certain mail and
then they thought right i can't be
having his kid specifically yeah i mean
maybe the first time but the second
third time 40 percent
do you guys know the history of uh like
why abortion was created and
whatnot
in the u.s in the u.s i don't know about
here but in the uk oh in the u.s
um i learned this from pearl but the
creator of was it planned parenthood the
creative planned parenthood
um overall the goal was to
essentially
decrease the population of
the black community so that was the goal
like if we
if we have abortion if we have this
option to where people can essentially
kill off the baby
let's give it to the communities that
are less fortunate and
the less fortunate communities
were the black communities and so it was
just like a cycle so that's essentially
why
planned parenthood was she was she was a
known eugenicist
and and they created marketing plans um
like specifically for minority
neighborhoods and then even today 80
percent of planned parenthood's in the
us are in black communities and the
black population would be double today
if there wasn't abortion and and there's
a 50 birth rate so 50 of all pregnancies
in the black community end in abortion
yeah so it's kind of messed up because
that was her goal and she's literally
achieving it today
i mean there's a lot of issues
with society
you know around
parenthood planned parenthood right so i
wouldn't
i mean
would it could anyone really say like
yeah i wish there was like more of a
certain kind of person based on
like the idea that so you said that
there would be like twice as many
african-americans etc yeah today was
i'm in favor of like population control
basically oh you're in favor of
population control like planned
parenthood in a sense
yeah as in like
no but you can have two two competing
ideologies right you can have which what
seems to be the conservative ideology
which is like just have kids have ten
whatever hustle see you know make ends
meet if they survive one of them could
be lil wayne you know et cetera and
that's cool okay okay now keep going
don't support single mothers don't
support anyone anything you do you you
pay the direct consequence of it and
that's that's that's it and society has
to pay that as well but that's it really
that's exactly what we say yeah that's
because that's why i see the
conservative perspective as when you
boil it down to what it is it seems like
because conservatives donate more than
liberals
but continue continuing i'm not talking
about like altruism or donation okay
okay but um and then there's the other
perspective which it's more lefty um
but the idea of like we have to kind of
try and
support a manager population in a way is
to have you know
manage the population growth in some way
you know especially for an advanced
economy if you have all these like
luxuries like you know healthcare all
these tech tech goods food everything
has to be carefully managed so and then
the costs have to be managed and the
quality of living has to be managed sure
so you're for abortion
yeah i've said that yeah so you can't
just have anyone having any kids because
then all those people go into this
carefully controlled and highly advanced
system and could cause all kinds of
hazards so i just have a question you
think
who should manage it
who should manage the population
it would have to go through like common
sense stuff i don't think it's an
individual but there'll be certain
policies that are aimed at supporting
responsible families parenthood et
cetera okay so so you think like
politicians in a sense should control
the population
no no like based on the laws that
they're passing you definitely said
policies yeah politicians control
policies but essentially they do using
your words
using your words if we were to go along
with uh so so in this case the
eugenicists like she was helping with
policy
and that did control a population you
think that was a net good yeah okay no
that that that that's not great the
history of it but obviously you know but
the abortion process it wasn't that good
though and that net goal and that good
as in as in it was a positive for
society
in the long run yeah the ability to have
abortions
i mean that's the ability to have
abortions the ability to wipe out 50 of
a
potential population yeah to control
population abortion yeah yeah by
controlling do you think controlling the
black population in the u.s isn't that
good
well that's that's that well you can
control any population right that's what
human beings will be doing all the time
so the idea of whether it's good or bad
is is irrelevant it's like is it good if
i punch you in the face people have been
doing that
you know the idea of
the population is being controlled
anyway okay even if you went through all
right-wing policies you're still being
me saying you can't have an abortion
it's still controlled
a specific example
if you said even if you go through
right-wing policies
the population is being controlled
anyway can i have a specific example
well if you were to say
well the what what um what was said
before about having eight to nine kids
and if one of them turns out to be lil
wayne
allowing these kids to go out in the
world and deal with who's who said lil
wayne sorry
one of them could be successful okay
then
they will be controlled by the
environment which in this that in this
day and age will be controlled by the
policies you make
we're not in the jungle anymore right so
these policies have direct influences
you don't think people have individual
decisions and choices and like a mind of
their own absolutely but we also
function as a society okay so the kind
of food you give people access to has an
effect of the population it kind of
influences the kind of procedures you
know allowing them access to abortion or
have an impact not allowing them access
to access to abortion has an impact okay
so you're being controlled anyway the
idea that like we can all just do what
we want okay so so you know i i have a
big family right and maybe i'm just
curious how am i being controlled
like i'm i'm in the west like how am i
being controlled you're controlled by a
larger society how um the kind of
schools you go to the kind of people you
have access to um you have to pay for
university the kind of jobs you have
access to when you graduate so so if i
if i
in 2022 i'm making a choice whether i
have sex or i don't have sex right
um
how how am i being controlled if when i
get to choose whether or not i use
protection or i don't use protection
how is a policy controlling me
well it controls the outcomes if
anything happens
okay but at the end of the day i have a
choice to be abstinent or not be
abstinent
yeah you have a choice but right yeah
right so i just don't understand how i'm
being controlled
[Music]
you're being controlled in a large on a
larger level so your individual choice
is still there but the fact is what the
outcome of whatever you do the outcome
must be decided by society if you have a
child you need a midwife you need you
know
child mortality was really high without
all this tech so if you could so by
having
hospitals and medical professionals
we're talking about policies so like i
think you're you're moving a little bit
here we're talking because you're that
now you're talking about technological
advancement we're talking about policies
yeah are you saying like uh that that
they won't be able to be um
they're gonna get suppressed or or
you know stop because they're not able
to have the same opportunities that a
smaller family would have or they they
wouldn't have like financial obligations
because the family is much much bigger
that would stop them from having certain
opportunities to go into certain schools
going
to certain places in society because
there's
it's too big a family and the
affordability would bring him into a low
class of citizen as per say
i'm just saying that these policies have
a direct impact on
on
the outcomes so so would you agree that
these policies have an impact like if
you say people can do this and not do
this that will have an impact on how
society is enlarged tends to like evolve
growth i think taking away
consequences has a negative impact and
i'm all for
making people face the consequences of
their own choices
so you want to control
no i don't i don't know it's lack of
control actually it's no government
control it's everyone pick what they
want to pick but deal with the
consequences
so if i want to be abstinent till i'm
married
that's that's one choice if i want to
have a kid out of wedlock that's another
choice but the government shouldn't bail
me out of my bad choices
that's like saying if you punch somebody
and they punch you back it's like why'd
you punch me back that's a consequence
for your actions yeah
i understand that approach but i'm not
governed by policy can i just say add to
that
that's not governed by policy
the consequence so if you punish me and
i'll punch you back it wasn't governed
by policy that was a choice that you
made and it had consequences
okay
so so having sex that's a choice and
there's consequence yeah and so if you
choose to have you can't afford to have
sex and don't have sex
but i i feel like what's always missing
from the conservative viewpoint is this
idea of
like
it's very ideol ideological of like yeah
like everyone should have to do what
they want and you know the outcome will
just happen in natural selection but it
doesn't work out like that like if you
say for example you don't support
single moms then we already know that
people from those backgrounds are
disproportionately likely to end you
know
less successful or problem mental health
issues those people then go into society
and cause other issues so republicans or
conservatives complain a lot about crime
and this and that but then you also say
let's not let's let's support the most
vulnerable households less
because you know free choice let them
face consequences it just seems like i
think i think right now women are
incentivized to leave
they're given an incentive to take the
father out of the home because they are
literally paid to do it if you pay
someone to like if you pay someone to
take the dad out of the choi out of the
home more people are going to do it
that's just common sense
so i to me if you took that away there
would be an incentive to keep families
together which is better for the kids
and the kids would have better outcomes
yeah that's true
they are incentivized to do that i think
the policies need a lot of work i'm not
saying the policies right now are great
i think
i i think society has to be controlled
um or managed in a way as to ensure the
most positive outcomes for the maximum
amount of people that's not to say that
like the policies we have now are good
so i do believe in right to choose but i
also believe in financial
abortion right equality i agree with you
yeah and i think i think that that's
balanced isn't it yeah because then you
take away the incentive to abuse a
system that supports wonderful people
actually i don't believe in abortion i
don't agree with you
but but i do agree if we're going to
have abortion legalized there should be
a financial abortion yeah there has to
be a balance right and i'm i'm not
saying the abortion thing is like the
only thing you could also ban abortion
but then there also has to be a balance
in terms of like making that work for
society or else you could create kind of
a pathway for people to be seen with
marginalized communities where you know
you systematically ban them from certain
higher education certain foods and then
you have a market or market abortion to
them you know that too yeah stuff like
that all these all these things that you
can do that you can directly impact a
population of people i'm just saying
that happens to everyone on a larger
scale and having that discussion around
policies and the real life impact is
like important um
so i do think we're being controlled
okay i'm gonna read some super chats um
this won't be fun
i don't know it's just been guys thank
you for the super chats get isha camera
hashtag get my man a camera
man
okay zmj
this is why black americans and africans
are always beefing because agents like
this are speaking on black issues with
no dog or awareness in the fight trained
to be a dog of the government a cyclone
steve women want authority over their
bodies but they don't want the
responsibility of that authority women
need
need a written agreement to get a child
support get child support sentience the
guest who guest who sits like a female
with a white hat you have painted
yourself to be embed
besible i don't know what a
um you lack knowledge and facts and
responding on feelings just like a
female please educate yourself with
facts but first use a tampon for your
vagina this guy's an emotion
um okay okay talver sun um bruh boot him
off um
vin lloyd and african supporting
eugenics wow
basha b planned parenthood was funded by
the same group of men who are funding
everything to do with woo flu and
vaccination um
xernax um the inequality of men um being
on the child support hook exists because
the government if the government doesn't
back up then where are the women at
hashtag take things taken things for
granted senior s t y x abortion existed
far before now time to take it out of
politicians hands to use a wedge to use
it as a
issue as no one can agree where life
begins bash should be give your super
chats give your chat some facts men
ridiculous to make statements you have
no understanding or statistical evidence
for i.e air pollution bs zmj lmao you
in the past you used to just nod and and
um you used you used to just a nod and
food on your table they got massive
respect because they knew the sacrifice
not this liberal
pandering we're told parenting today
ernest damien single mom households tend
to create bad people men who are there
but work a lot less than that single dad
house load holds produce less bad people
than single mom households do dad's
working hard doesn't normally produce
bad people because they are still there
ian mack um how do how did how many of
steve harvey's kids ended up being armed
robbers
sentience
in
individuals
individualistic lifestyles you mean like
we don't need a man be a boss babe we
can do anything we want but we're ready
for a family there aren't any good
men around movement the rubbish fueled
by hedonism and ig larry ray the white
hat sounds like a lightweight eugenic
supporter being poor does not
necessarily equal equal criminal
criminality william ray girl in the
right corner not making any sense ian um
ian mack
this really sounds like a case of people
growing up with bad fathers and assuming
that's the only path for them lack of
faith in self the uk economist i have to
correct your guests areas in britain
that have stable two parent homes have
less crimes every community with broken
homes breeds violence layla bella
different cultures have different values
kids are the retirement plan in some
cultures they will look after you in old
age sentience that to the
mangina in the corner and the other
female and the white cat i read this one
and then write cap stop feeling if
you're ruled by emotions you will lack
the fortitude to do what is required of
men learn to think be stoic and act with
conviction
star king colorful shirt guy is
projecting
chevy rita um women do not women
absolutely do not create life they carry
the life men put inside of them all life
on earth both animals and plants starts
with the seed um chevy ryda um five
dollar super chat no message i always
appreciate the real ones um clockwise um
women's entire biology has evolved to
reproduce her choice but not creating a
baby will make her feel incomplete all
those periods are for nothing the uk
economist your guests realize that the
homeless epidemic is going to happen in
the future single low earning unmarried
women are going to be on the streets
jake people are just incredibly self
self-centered materialistic and selfish
today whether you are religious or even
just from a biological sense we are
called to reproduce and propagate the
species tell her some black guy with the
hat you are making us look bad
pearl give this boy the blue
acamu the increase in mental health
issues is caused by a lack of resolving
challenges when they're younger they
were provided by a father in the home as
they encourage the child to figure child
to figure it out otis wellington it's
important for people to understand we're
all supposed to have kids if you don't
you're denying a biological
responsibility
britt cormier having a baby is not a
superpower and giving birth is not a
miracle people are born every day and
it's not due to anything supernatural
natural this language is bs and created
to gas women up
larry ray um women in the white well
dude in the white hat um is a
died in the wool beta and a super saiyan
terrell clark social media pro is prawn
for women
attention is their currency validation
is the cr
drug of choice at sign language is their
weapon of choice
and then are there any more ish well i
was reading them yeah yeah that was okay
okay let me let me go hold on i gotta
refresh the page
um
tough crowd
i'm not gonna lie to you strange that
air pollution thing is literally okay
okay okay house of house the dude sounds
authoritarian wow real um wow read more
bro mr fisher bro in the white hat
sounds like he lacks common sense his
arguments have no merits a lack
foundation he can't even explain himself
son what in the world are you living in
delusion at its finest zmg oh okay that
was it
yes some more just come in oh there's
more okay i'm very sorry guys
i'm not gonna lie that i'm getting paid
i'm getting roasted
[Music]
this out this boy's gonna get me
okay um abcon there's no favoritism in
the system but if you stay there for too
long it will cost poverty and laziness
okay is that it yeah okay
okay um well we've been going for a
minute so i think we're gonna wrap up
the show why don't we go around everyone
say any final thoughts that you had um
you can roast the commenters back if you
want
and where the people can find you so you
can start
well what a show
[Music]
my final thoughts well
i think similar to
i think the general consensus on the
room is that um
yeah you
you you have the ability to
to make decisions and
just know that whichever decision you
make you'll have a consequence
if you choose
uh to be a feminist if you don't choose
to be a feminist no really know what
you're getting yourself into because a
lot of us say that we are or pretend
that we are or we want to act like we
are but we don't actually know what
what were giving up in in return so i'm
jt aka king babs uh king babs you can
find me on social that's k-i-n-g b-a-v-s
and make sure to follow pearl's channel
thank you
um final thoughts um i always think like
the conversations that are on the show
are needed in just regular society
because
here people can sit down disagree have
different opinions and have a
conversation but like out in the world
is very very
um
taboo to be able to sit down with
someone and be able to disagree and have
a conversation like oh i see where
you're coming from the stat in the third
but um my final thoughts is just think
before you make decisions
and you can find me on um instagram at
its.yah.girlunderscorejess
and you can find me on youtube as well
it's it's your girl jess
i think my reflections are quite similar
just um
instead of saying i'm this i'm that like
saying an ideology just actually
do some self-reflection and think about
what your values are and live those
don't say a label and then
i don't know pretend to everyone that
you're following all of that literally
think about what's important to you
and um
and your values and just go with that
and accept responsibility for your
actions as well
thank you
oh my instagram
oh sorry it's a weird instagram it's a
0ct 4v1 a i'm sorry about that but
that's my instagram it spells octavia in
numbers and letters
thank
you
well that was a very interesting show
lots of different viewpoints
i would say
guys don't get married
and
stay away from it protect yourself look
after yourself
and uh if you're thinking about getting
married probably not in the west that's
probably the best idea
see boys we up
so um
i'm talking about accept me and jess
but uh yeah guys it's too dangerous
seriously it is too dangerous to get
married nowadays protect yourself look
after yourself be careful out there on
these streets
uh if you can find me at stefan s t e f
a n x alexander i like alexander the
great that's my instagram i have i run a
crypto based show on youtube under money
space gang space crypto and you can find
that there as well shout out to richard
hart and uh also
yeah i did used to do kind of red pill
subjects under red pill realities
there's some stuff there but i haven't
done some stuff on that because i got
cancelled on tick tock so uh feel free
to follow me on those socials
that's about it thanks for having me on
the show
yeah thank you guys for coming go ahead
uh closing thoughts um yeah interesting
conversation
um
and i would say you know probably just
try and make informed decisions protect
yourself xyz be very i wouldn't say
don't get mad but be very cautious
about how you engage in things like
marriage and the kind of decisions you
make
and try and stay as informed as possible
as the air pollution and kind of the
challenges that our generation are going
to be facing in terms of you know
falling fertility rates etc um my
socials
uh s-u-n-t-o-c-h-u-k-w-u
um santochuku and yeah you can hit me up
if you want um you know some sources as
to some of the stats i mentioned oh if
you wanna you know if you think you can
uh
tango with me in terms of these
discussions um and uh
yeah
okay um there's one more super chat and
it's funny you said air pollution um
white white hat air pollution no two
levels have dropped year on year and are
the lowest they have been in 50 years
learn the stats not the rhetoric
i don't okay
okay um all right guys um thank you so
much you all
all right thank you guys so much for
coming um i know we don't agree but we
don't all agree but it's really nice to
have these conversations and you guys
are really important to the show so i
really really appreciate you coming
especially you guys you came on very
short notice so very much appreciate it
um guys do not forget to subscribe to
the channel like the video on your way
out try to get to a thousand likes
before the stream ends um don't forget
to sign up for our memberships
and i will talk to you next time bye
and that's a wrap
boom